another film under the belt of the
Disney Empire I'm pretty sure if you
write Disney in the air and swap the
letters around like Tom Riddle or
something it'll spelled Skynet did that
each they're annexing everything under
there but I'm just saying and here we
are again here's another one let's
review
buona semana is the newest Disney
animated film this one stars the rock
and a girl it was a newcomer whose name
I I'm going to butcher it if I say
that's her name and you should know that
name you're probably gonna hear it a lot
more because her voice is amazing and in
Moana Moana is a princess of these
Island folks they don't really explore
they just stay on their Island is hang
out there's a demigod out there named
Maui played by the rock who stole
something she needs to go find him and
have him return something that he stole
so the two team up and they have to go
on this quest which is a lot like Legend
of Zelda Wind Waker for a lot of it you
give me an adventure on water with a
little sailboat and some good music I'm
gonna think Wind Waker now I might think
Moana who knows first of all the rocket
is but his charisma comes through even
just in the voice at this point the rock
has proven that he is a superstar and he
is here to stay he's done what very few
wrestlers before him have actually done
but he really I love his character
because his character is kind of a date
like I've said man I love my
entertaining ass
sarcastic pricks we're kind of lovable
because they're voiced by the rock all
one of them now which is that dude but
it brought a lot of entertainment factor
and she has to say this sentence dooms
something like now it is basically ello
my name is Inigo Montoya you killed my
father prepare to die like that
her name's not inigo montoya now he
didn't kill her father and he's not
she's not going to kill him so it's a
very different phrase but it reminded me
of actually she kept having to say it
doing I was a tangent that was so
useless for this review I'm keeping it
in though not cutting that but seriously
the weight of this entire film is based
on these twos on their shoulders it's on
the chemistry of these two the rock and
a newcomer to the voice-acting world to
carry a film so yeah new Disney film no
pressure you too and they do it they
really do it's done because Maui in this
film is a layered character there's more
to him than meets the eye you know that
from the get-go and the movie properly
explores that ad in an adventure the
takes you to the heights and depths of
the ocean how's that not great
entertainment oh and great music - oh my
god yeah the soundtrack be prepared to
get your kids a soundtrack this year
yeah not only is the music as a whole
great but it has a couple of songs in
here that yeah you member let it go I
don't know if it'll reach the heights of
let it go I don't know if it's gonna get
burned out as much as let it go I'm just
saying it's coming prepare you want to
see every parent out there right now now
that I said every parent watching this
is like sandwich begins as you're
watching the movie enjoy it's a good
music that's the core of this film as it
is 99.99999% if disney animated films is
heart
it has good heart has a good lesson
mallanna could very well be a new Disney
classic if I can find a flaw and I'm
really digging for the flaws one of them
be like it just like Wind Waker there's
a lot of time out there on the ocean
where you have downtime you can see it
as bringing the film down although I
didn't I just have to address it that
some people might and the ending is
executed it's exciting until it's
anticlimactic however my argument for it
is if you're going to give me an anti
climactic ending give me an anti
climactic ending as for the betterment
of the story of the film
you're gonna compromise the excitement
give me the goods give me the heart give
me a field and this movie pulled that
off it was great in the end in a world
where animated films been pretty good
this year
one is another staple the animated films
this year are proof that 2016 was not a
venomously divisive ass horde year not
just anyway we have ourselves from
cartoon I can't wait to see Moana again
I will say Moana is awesome tacular
right guys some wanna have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite animated film this year
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more